[Musique]
à coucher dehors l'hiver les hivers fait
la bise qu'il faut les branchés mais des
tempêtes il va digérer les bâches ou ça
il faut là il faut les biens les
attacher
[Musique]
kiala obs c'est bien que mal une
température de base en juillet a ou
perd près vous arrivez dans fin de
saison by tombe de la flotte sur glace
brandela la voiture vous savez vous êtes
à l'abri pouvez y aller quoi sert à
faire un type ému voire à café chez
buchet michel
je sais bien qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
ils disent en bas ça c'est une pub elle
c'est un conte seuls cinq ans figure
enfin moi je laisse parler pour moi moi
je suis à l'abri mois moi je m'occupe
pas des autres m'occupe de moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
sur les autoroutes c'est interdit passé
s'est désigné comme une mobylette mais
comment vous arrivez à savoir c'est
interdit est autorisé si vous n'êtes pas
le permis
bah
bah si c'est interdit interdit ça te
dire que quand vous avez un sens
interdit c'est interdit bon vous avez
des sens interdits et des sens uniques à
prendre par exemple que vous allez
souvent seul ou vieillit beaucoup de
sens interdit il a dédié des feux et
tout ça hein c'est pas vous arrêter mes
valises il faut faire attention quand je
préfère arrêter dans la somme qui sera
toujours prendre
sa priorité et respecter le code de ces
voitures là
moi je dis qu'il faut savoir me navre et
manoeuvré sa voiture malgré sa conduite
est pas trop boire par second conduit
jean marc est de boire mais rares et
accord je suis pour le corps à me suivez
ce qui produit quand on voit un petit
coup moi j'ai ce point d'acheter on
appelle ça des gâteaux éponge alors des
gâteaux et pons sont des gâteaux qui
bourre pour éponger l'alcool pas empêché
le de des limites face à limoux l'alcool
pour se sentir bien en volant les
gendarmes sont là pour faire leur boulot
hein et ils ont raison et d'abord c'est
ça devient quand un accord et sous et
ben c'est un danger de mort et peut
faire beaucoup d'accidents
moi je suis à cheval là dessus et parce
que c'est bien que je conduis bien un
bon bah je dis pas que dans ce 3e
fraction ça peut arriver à tout le monde
mais après on réfléchit on agit après
quand on a fait de traction il ya là
d'eau qu'ils ont des voitures avec le
père minifone fraction même les camions
les deux fois des camions ils respectent
pas la priorité à droite à et moi
j'étais souvenons jour bas il faisait
pas attention à je croyais bien qu'il ya
un cas c'est ma voiture
[Musique]